you know i love a west coast love story
okay and this one is about a husband a
wife and their garlic noodle so allow me
to introduce you to the blue kitchen
garlic noodle bar owners chef grubby
and sonny johnson they're here to show
us what they're all about
now l.a to vegas
what is the blue face what is the blue
flavor explain that to us uh our surfing
turf garlic noodles it was a popular
item i did
when we were selling out the house
this item had lines going out the
kitchen to the backyard i love that yeah
so when we were able to get a food truck
i was like hey let's do the first
gardening little trip wow and this is
all in l.a
this is all nelly so the underground
kind of la food scene
to a whole entire restaurant brick and
mortar here in las vegas and we were
doing so we was just making so much
noise in l.a i was like we got to go
today
this is la's backyard we have to go to
vegas exactly you know we love you know
la you know move to vegas i did the same
thing okay so let's talk about what the
food has and what makes it special and
you know just
walk us through it what makes it special
is the sauce we use for the garlic
noodles and we like to marinate
overnight okay uh and that just goes
yeah and i would say you can you know
you can take your date to the restaurant
but you know
at least at least you're both
you know garlic
you're definitely gonna need something
right okay so walk us through how does
it work when we come into the restaurant
this is one of the top items okay steak
the steak in the shrimp but this steak
right here and with this sauce
this just brings it up a notch okay so
i'm gonna put some sauce on it go for it
go for it let's see this is the you you
call this the aioli right yes look at
that which is our house sauce oh my god
somebody um somebody on the review said
it's hard to explain
but it hits the spot what do you think
they meant by that
first bite is like you're speechless
oh yeah yeah put some chives on it oh
look okay but enough on there yeah okay
okay okay
one little mochis
boom
this is the kind of meal that you have
to make sure you get every layer in one
bite right yes
oh my gosh so
chef grubby
you said this is grassroots do you have
a culinary background at all or where
does the inspiration come you know what
i couldn't afford to go to school i'm
not going to be black right
so uh you know i found out the
curriculum was only where i could order
it from amazon and i just learned on my
own and youtube and you know it just
became one of the best chefs in l.a fire
huh
oh no i can't even talk now
oh my gosh this is so good it is wow
this is like percentage of the menu like
we have a korean sticky wing we have
snow crab egg rolls
lamb chops sea bass on the weekend yes
it's this is just a smidge so y'all got
to come check us out exactly and this is
not only about food y'all are setting an
example you're building a community what
does it mean to you to have this space
for yourself in the community oh this is
like our baby like he's been wanting
like a sit down restaurant for so long
you know the food the food truck was
just for us to get to where we really
wanted to go so it was like now he has
like a playground and he can just i
finally have do what he wants you know
so you know well this isn't my first
sit-down restaurant because me and my
brother taco mail in l.a we also have
the court cafe cafe i know that's what
it is
um and but this is mine okay this is
something where i can just go in there
and just create and do whatever i want
to well i'm so excited for y'all this
food is good you have to try it tell
them where they can find you really
quick
west cheyenne 7450